[Musica]
Y
diaz alla città
davis jr
pasticcini
Dentro il marciapiede della torsione mi amo
a lucy roseta non lo so
chiama il tuo cane
e con lui
[Musica]
la lettera ha rotto l'autobus
e ogni Francesco
il
pietà
stesso uomo
sì
michu
Giamaica
sì
dalla città
è solo teoria telematica
e famoso liquido
per me
la notte quando lo fai
Bene, signore, dove ci sarebbe?
le notizie
Già
[Musica]
Y
signorina giamaica zia
[Musica]
Ho indossato
sì
Yo
[Musica]
vale a dire
la mente
la prossima canzone in cui la forza
qui ho pulito
Giusto
[Musica]
ciao
oh
con casa
[Musica]
dal 23 marzo
con la traccia di gomma
[Musica]
hanno appena lasciato la strada
[Applausi]
[Musica]
Dio che sorpresa voglio andare
ci vediamo al mio fianco
[Musica]
[Applausi]
cocaina
della mia logica
fino al cappello
[Musica]
Yo
ronis
[Musica]
restrizioni
sodio
dice di essere identico a te
e quali cose spara
e
quell'eroina
millennio
[Musica]
anche la poppa
il rivale uno scherzo
[Musica]
'la Francia oggi
questo sta arrivando alla nostra ultima canzone è
Ho detto di aver colpito l'ingrato mototv
válter il peperoncino da molano prossimo uguale
eterotopia
[Musica]
altia norberto da dove un applauso
Adornare
Y
Yo
Ho acceso la macchina
guarda la palla media
marta nel tema ha violato il destino
non più
sulla croce ha cantato da solo poiché durante il giorno
e prodotto in bree monica vitti
quando bere il tè
[Musica]
d
prostata
all'interno di tale
passato i tempi difficili
il grano
pieno attento e leonese
4 e comico
estratto di limone con bayati torrentino
la comparsa foto del momento
[Musica]
frutti di bosco
solo musica orrenda e parte poetica
h
quando è finito
[Musica]
questo
Marley come architetto professore di
chimica
torta di papà
[Musica]
costo verde del dipinto di notte
nella coda del leone
[Musica]
terrestar in navantía goccia d'acqua
e dimmi
contiamo la tua TV più latte che vengono a dire
il mio impegno per te e per l'appartamento
Preferisco tuffarmi in mare
Sono mat i tic
quando canto della pasta già di federico
[Musica]
quando ho cantato l'hai cacciata fuori
corre
sì
[Musica]
Ho preso un previsto
due suite e cosa vuoi suonare
questo
di Scioli
[Musica]
ti costa amore in dollari e sanz
un
cronologia dei salti temporali
oh
[Musica]
[Applausi]